did you know with vertex AI you can
interact with tune customize and embed
Foundation models into your applications
with no machine learning expertise
required with imagine accessed through
generative AI studio in vertex AI or via
API you can even generate and edit
images and when we say no expertise we
mean it you can generate or edit images
from a simple text prompt and that
includes the ability to extract the
background or edit specific Parts using
a mask area that you define you can even
tune the model with reference images
that align with your brand and you don't
need thousands of them to get the
results you want training a new custom
style only requires a few reference
images and then you can prompt the model
with your style reference and get the
new image consistent with your Unique
Style or you can choose something
predefined for common style choices like
watercolor